he started his business with $20,000 at
his wife and his friend helped him raise
he's the first mainline China
entrepreneur to be featured on the cover
of Forbes magazine he's the richest man
in China and the 18th richest man in the
world with an estimated fortune of
twenty nine point seven billion dollars
he's Jack Ma founder of Alibaba calm and
here are his 10 rules for success when I
graduate from universities and before
you know for three years I tried fill in
the universities so I applied jobs for
30 times got rejected
I went for a police they say no you're
not good I went to you know even the KFC
when KFC came to check up do I say 30 24
people went for the job 23 people
accepted I was the only guy and we went
for please five people all of them
accepted I was the only guy did I
receive receive it so to me being turned
down rejected out by the way I told you
that I would apply for Harvard for 10
times rejected
I know 10 times you wrote them and said
I'd like to come to Harvard
yeah and then I told myself someday I
should go teach there baby just like
Open Sesame
is a secret code for Alibaba the secret
code for everybody's keep your dream
alive because it might come true someday
this is what the secret
what do you think your core competence
is I'll call its culture it's not the
technology I think technologies are to
the core competence of our companies we
have 220 Fowler grow from 18 people to
now 2d thousand young people and we
focus a lot on the value in a mission
and making sure the culture everybody
work for helping others instead of how
instead of you know just to make you
money people don't like it so many
people I talked to at that time for Olli
pay they say this is the stupidest idea
you have ever got but I say I don't wear
the stupid Club as long as people use it
now we have 800 million people using
this Ali pay I learned a lot of things
from from movies I learned how to make a
speech from the movie code bodyguard
Whitney Houston when she sings the Suns
I look at her wow that's the way that
you make a speaker because I never know
how to make speech because I'm not actor
but when I saw the movie I said wow if
you sing from your heart if you've seen
naturally if you are yourself so I I
realize and I learn a lot from the
movies you know even learn from the
Godfather's I learned my favorite movies
the forest the gum you know these these
are the things that learned so much then
I will discuss about the the muse the
inspiration so we got from movies what
kinds of business ideas have you said no
to I'm saying no to a lot of ideas
because as a CEO I have to see no two
opportunities because if I say yes I
probably get a 5,000 opportunities every
day but where the years are know
everything based on the meshing that
were helping is doing business easier if
it's on that we'll consider if our
somebody come here saying can you will
you don't have this issue you will make
a lot of money I'm not interested why
did you call it Allah baba Ali Baba
well when I started I think Internet is
below but we should have a global name
and a name that Inc
like at that time the best the name is
Yahoo right I think I can so I've been
thinking for many days suddenly Alibaba
is a good name so I I was happened to
being sent San Francisco that day never
didn't have a lunch and the waitress can
I ask you do you know about Alibaba
should you say yes I see what is Alibaba
she said Open Sesame
good so I went on the street ask about
10 20 people they all know about Alibaba
40 thieves and Open Sesame
and I think this is a good name and
start with a whatever you talk about all
the bubbles on the top we believe the
coke on very different from the Wall
Street would be the custom number one
employee number two share a number for
customer one employee to share number
three yeah are we again this is my
religion you know if you it's the custom
that pays the money it's the employees
that drive the innovation it's the
shareholding share would always say you
know I remember the day before we IPO
and a lot of people say can I keep up
the shares we were long-term
shareholders but when the crisis came
these guys buy custom stay where the is
where where the trouble
our team can was a potential for a from
better came from humble home since a
union or main focuses on the Templars
news over here Raja
Tony paella solo debut support for years
from young reality pizza
this is for example our support attack
one is for its origins in Greece too
close to each other so the super fish
shop and then jumping will jump to each
other the Union champio gender machine
just a funny thought doesn't work she
won Fanta
so we're not that people leave it open
septum is what you think I don't know
what it's a Honda Kim how the public
well the concern over the Conchita are
gonna be achieved I want you to assume
the cheese
thank you guys for watching the question
of the day for you is I want to know
what kind of rejection you've had to
overcome in your life and in your
business if you've had to overcome a lot
of rejection you have a special story to
share I'd love to hear from you if you
want to leave a comment below I made
this video on Jack Ma because Jeff Liang
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
leave a comment let me know what you
think and I'll see what I can do and of
course if you like this video and you
want to see more don't forget to
subscribe to the newsletter and the
channel thank you for watching continue
to believe have an amazing day and I
hope you'll start your day again with me
tomorrow with another inspirational
video